I mean we haven't been introduced to
again oh my god me get there nice to
meet you name oh my god
[Music]
we're so excited to be here with Jordan
Peele excited to be here hey directorial
debut forget out we watched it go see
the movie it is we were terrified yes we
were terrified we're gonna do something
fun called pew pew pew pew I'm excited
for pew pew pew um this is our rapid
fire sex
this is our rapid question fire segment
that's all right
the words don't have to be in order I
think things may don't get him out you
just got to get him out um what does
your childhood smell like mmm
skittles and rain really yeah that's
really cute
it's our yeah I was just thinking it's
like beautiful hey how much you know
that's that's the two of my favorite
things okay okay
was there a moment you ever rebelled
with your white mom good why mom you
don't get me did you call her away my
mother wears blue wears black mama met
up somewhere white mother not understand
no you know I didn't have any sort of
like racial rebellion um and anyway I'd
you know I had the normal high school
sure like angst thing for a bit but I
was pretty know my mama's boy I was
pretty I'm pretty much and she did you
know she did a real good job so let's do
some would you rather would you rather
vote for the presidency of the United
States Rachel Dolezal Oh or Omarosa
Oh Richard Dolezal one second wait why
talk to me you thought about that in
like two seconds yeah I think um Rachel
Dolezal Lula has spent her life trying
to do good things she's been working for
black people it's confusing right
because she wants the black anybody what
you doing yeah it's not what you want
I think her big mistake like she could
have gotten away with just being like
yeah like my hair like this I like that
she just didn't have to say like my
parents are black okay
did everyone work yeah so one of my
would you rather this was based on
partly in truth so you're a woman in
this situation hey girl wait man
we haven't been introduced to who I am
he good oh my god me get there nice to
meet you name oh my god would you rather
go on a date with a man who has a pickup
truck but no need for it or a man who
has five cats
hmm I would say that I've emailed I man
with a pickup chat with five cats and
let me tell you ladies he was good Oh so
do you think that is something about the
pickup truck you just wanna you want a
guy who can just knows how to haul that
be off that's to I you approve
I can't believe my crew I don't see that
coming at you second let's set it up and
set it on yep it was a layup and then I
was just like yes I saw nothing
[Music]